As the discussion over how to address climate change heats up this Earth Day, we're taking a look at how people understand the risks of climate change and how they adapt. In this episode, we talk with two psychologists who study everything from communication to behavior change and discuss how psychological research can contribute to an understanding of global climate change. I'm Andre Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Janet Swim is a professor of psychology at the Pennsylvania State University. She chaired the American Psychological Association Task Force on psychological perspectives on climate change. She is currently examining how people's beliefs about climate change are influenced by others,
随着地球日临近，关于如何应对气候变化的讨论愈演愈烈，我们正在审视人们如何理解气候变化的风险以及如何适应。在本期节目中，我们采访了两位心理学家，他们研究的领域涵盖从沟通到行为改变的方方面面，并讨论了心理学研究如何有助于理解全球气候变化。我是安德烈·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。珍妮特·斯威姆是宾夕法尼亚州立大学的心理学教授。她曾担任美国心理学会气候变化心理学视角特别工作组的主席。她目前正在研究人们对气候变化的信念如何受到他人的影响，
as well as how to encourage people to support pro-environmental behaviors. Also with us is John Fraser. He is a conservation psychologist, architect, and educator, serving as president and CEO for the New York Think Tank New Knowledge Organization. His current research focuses on how social relationships and social relationships and media influence how people choose to engage in solving big social problems like climate change mitigation, resolving health disparities, or creating positive opportunities for youth to become their best selves. They are working together with the National Network for Ocean and Climate Change Interpretation, which has the goal of training educators on how to effectively communicate climate change information.
以及如何鼓励人们支持环保行为。与我们同行的还有约翰·弗雷泽。他是一位保护心理学家、建筑师和教育家，担任纽约智库“新知识组织”的总裁兼首席执行官。他目前的研究重点是社会关系和媒体如何影响人们选择参与解决重大社会问题，如减缓气候变化、解决健康差异或为年轻人创造最佳自我发展的积极机会。他们正在与国家海洋和气候变化解释网络合作，该网络的目标是培训教育工作者如何有效地传播气候变化信息。
Welcome Dr. Swim and Dr. Fraser. Thank you. Thanks very much. First and foremost, this is the most basic question, but how is psychology contributing to the discussion about climate change? Well, I would say that there are probably two major ways that psychology is contributing. One way is that a lot of psychologists look into behavioral change, and so there are issues about getting individuals to change everyday behaviors, and individuals to engage in civic action contacting their political officials and things like that.
欢迎斯威姆博士和弗雷泽博士。谢谢。非常感谢。首先，这是一个最基本的问题，心理学是如何为气候变化的讨论做出贡献的？嗯，我想说心理学做出贡献的方式主要有两种。一种方式是许多心理学家研究行为改变，因此存在让个人改变日常行为的问题，以及让个人参与公民行动，联系他们的政治官员等。
The other is a broader perspective and bringing in issues of environmental justice and thinking about the ways that climate change affect people, minority groups, the people in vulnerable parts of the world, both in the United States actually and across the planet. I think there's been a lot of conversation about how people understand the facts of climate change, but very little about how we process it in our minds. And that is really going to be key to any kind of future change, and that's where psychologists can be really useful. Are people's behaviors changing when it comes to taking steps to help prevent climate change,
另一种是更广阔的视角，引入环境正义问题，思考气候变化如何影响人们、少数群体、世界脆弱地区的人们，实际上包括美国境内和全球各地。我认为关于人们如何理解气候变化的事实已经有很多讨论，但关于我们如何在头脑中处理这些信息却知之甚少。这对于未来的任何变革都至关重要，而这正是心理学家可以发挥巨大作用的地方。当涉及到采取措施帮助预防气候变化时，人们的行为是否正在改变，
such as being more energy, conscious, recycling? Yeah, I think they have changed. It's a slow movement. It's not going to happen all at once, but you can see things across the country. And even at our universities, there are lots more committees being formed and task force and trying to change institutions that way. So I think we actually are seeing a lot of change in the United States. I think it's such a big question about what you can.
比如更有环保意识、回收利用？是的，我认为他们已经改变了。这是一个缓慢的过程。它不会一蹴而就，但你可以在全国各地看到变化。即使在我们的大学里，也成立了更多的委员会和特别工作组，试图以这种方式改变机构。所以我认为我们实际上在美国看到了很多变化。我认为关于你能做什么，这是一个很大的问题。
can do that when people think at small levels like turning off lights or recycling, they're really not systemically organizing it in their minds about how can they deal with the biggest problem, because it's pretty overwhelming when we start to think about the scale of climate change and what our little actions are going to be. But these collective actions are really starting to show. Why do some people reject the notion of climate change occurring at all? Is there some sort of psychological reasoning behind this? Well, I definitely think there is some psychological reasoning behind it. I think there's two conversations there. in that question that I think it's important to unpack. The first is that there aren't that many
当人们在小范围内思考，比如关灯或回收利用时，他们并没有在头脑中系统地组织如何应对最大的问题，因为当我们开始思考气候变化的规模以及我们微小的行动将产生什么影响时，这相当令人不知所措。但这些集体行动确实开始显现出来。为什么有些人完全拒绝气候变化正在发生这一概念？这背后是否有某种心理原因？嗯，我绝对认为这背后有某种心理原因。我认为这个问题中有两个对话，我认为拆解它们很重要。首先，并没有那么多人
people who really deny climate change. It's about 5% of our country doesn't think it's possible. There are a lot of people who are questioning whether climate change or what the mechanisms are, but it's not denial. That's a kind of propaganda story. I mean, 8% of America thinks Elvis is still alive. So it's not really a fact that people don't get it. It's understanding how it works. So we're arguing over facts that everyone agrees on. What the real issue is, is that how do people understand climate change in their lives and practically how they can relate to the topic? I also say that part of the issues that people are not talking about climate change either.
真正否认气候变化。我们国家大约有5%的人认为它是不可能的。有很多人在质疑气候变化是什么或其机制是什么，但这并不是否认。那是一种宣传故事。我的意思是，8%的美国人认为猫王还活着。所以人们不理解它并不是一个事实。关键在于理解它是如何运作的。所以我们是在争论每个人都同意的事实。真正的问题是，人们如何在生活中理解气候变化，以及实际上他们如何与这个话题产生联系？我还想说，部分问题在于人们也没有在谈论气候变化。
And so there's a part of the message when people think the other people are not believing in climate change, then they think that they don't want to be the ones to say something, but actually a lot of people do. And so they need to just start talking about it with each other and start very. figuring out what it means for them and what they can do, what they can't do, what they're feeling like they're able to do. I mean, that's really the heart of our research, is how do we get people engaged in a conversation and something that is proactively imagining themselves in the solution instead of pretending no one believes it, and there we just don't talk about it so we don't know where to go. And it has been politicized.
因此，当人们认为其他人不相信气候变化时，信息中就有一部分是他们不想成为那个说出来的人，但实际上很多人都相信。所以他们只需要开始互相谈论它，并开始弄清楚这对他们意味着什么，他们能做什么，不能做什么，他们觉得能做什么。我的意思是，这确实是我们研究的核心，即我们如何让人们参与到对话中，并主动想象自己参与解决方案，而不是假装没有人相信它，然后我们就不谈论它，所以我们不知道该往哪里走。而且它已经被政治化了。
That's probably the biggest problem, is it facts have been politicized. and one of the things that the National Network for Ocean Climate Change interpretation is trying to do is take the politics away and get it back to practical action. And how can psychologists inform policy discussions in this area? One of the biggest roles for psychologists is really how do we talk about what is possible, what is our potential future. When we think about policy, I mean, I'll tell you, our research is funded by the National Science Foundation. We are not involved in policy discussions in our research.
这可能是最大的问题，事实已经被政治化了。国家海洋和气候变化解释网络试图做的事情之一就是消除政治因素，回归实际行动。心理学家如何为该领域的政策讨论提供信息？心理学家最大的作用之一确实是我们如何谈论什么是可能的，什么是我们潜在的未来。当我们考虑政策时，我的意思是，我告诉你，我们的研究是由国家科学基金会资助的。我们不参与研究中的政策讨论。
But when I think as an individual about policy, one of the things psychologists can certainly do is help people understand what they can be as a political actor, someone who is advocating for positive change that's going to make the world a better place. That's my individual opinion, not the project, though. I'd also say that there's a thing that psychologists can do is to help policy makers understand what people are thinking and feeling about climate change and be part of the communication to tell policy makers. that people are concerned about this, and to be that voice, to make them realize that there's that concern. A lot of policy focuses on things that are economic and structure, but we get concerned about issues of justice, because there are people who are going to lose just because of where they live, how they live, or where they are in the economic spectrum. And one of the things that we know from the general population is most people really care
但当我作为一个个体思考政策时，心理学家当然可以做的一件事是帮助人们理解他们可以成为什么样的政治参与者，一个倡导积极变革、让世界变得更美好的人。这是我个人的观点，而不是项目的观点。我还想说，心理学家可以做的一件事是帮助政策制定者理解人们对气候变化的想法和感受，并参与沟通，告诉政策制定者人们对此感到担忧，并成为那种声音，让他们意识到这种担忧。很多政策关注的是经济和结构问题，但我们关注正义问题，因为有些人仅仅因为他们居住的地方、生活方式或在经济谱系中的位置而遭受损失。我们从普通民众那里知道的一件事是，大多数人真的很关心
and want people to be protected. They want to live in a peaceful society. They don't want conflict. And so if we continue to talk about economics and not about the justice for people who are front-line living in places that are going to be threatened, like people who live in Micronesia, then we really aren't being good people. So I think we can get engaged in those kind of policy decisions. How can psychologists improve communication about the very real impacts of climate change and what people can do to help address the threat? You know, it's an interesting question.
并希望人们得到保护。他们希望生活在一个和平的社会中。他们不想要冲突。因此，如果我们继续谈论经济，而不是谈论那些生活在受威胁地区（如密克罗尼西亚）的前线人民的正义，那么我们真的不是好人。所以我认为我们可以参与这些政策决定。心理学家如何改善关于气候变化真实影响以及人们可以采取什么措施来应对威胁的沟通？你知道，这是一个有趣的问题。
Our research started long before Janet and I were collaborating. I was working for a conservation organization, the Wildlife Conservation Society in New York City, and we found that in our meetings there was a very elevated sense of concern, almost what looked like panic in some conversations. That started a project that eventually got sewed into the project we're working on today. We were looking at the emotional experience of knowing the problem. And climate change is really a threatening issue. People see the world around them, changing and leaving them, and that is emotionally. distressing when you know the facts. When you can see the evidence, it is distressing. And when you
我们的研究早在珍妮特和我合作之前就开始了。我当时在纽约市的一个保护组织——野生动物保护协会工作，我们发现我们的会议中有一种非常强烈的担忧感，在某些对话中几乎看起来像是恐慌。这开启了一个项目，最终被缝合进我们今天正在进行的项目中。我们正在研究了解问题的情绪体验。气候变化确实是一个威胁性的问题。人们看到周围的世界在改变并离他们而去，当你了解事实时，这在情感上是令人痛苦的。当你能看到证据时，它是令人痛苦的。而当你
think people around you don't believe you, you self-edit because the emotional labor that goes into doing that work is difficult. So what we find is that people who know the facts, who understand what's necessary, who are working in frontline conservation jobs, who are working as educators, are emotionally distressed and avoiding the emotional labor of getting involved in the work. what we're trying to do is help these folks to see that there is a possible future, there is a possible narrative. And I think this is a real job across the many different kinds of psychology, from positive psychology to consumer psychology to justice, to peace. All of these topics deal with emotionally difficult work. And I think we need to focus on the worker's personal life
认为周围的人不相信你时，你会进行自我审查，因为进行这项工作所付出的情感劳动是困难的。所以我们发现，了解事实、了解必要性、在保护前线工作、担任教育工作者的人，在情感上感到痛苦，并避免参与这项工作的情感劳动。我们试图做的是帮助这些人看到有一个可能的未来，有一个可能的叙事。我认为这是心理学各个领域的一项真正的工作，从积极心理学到消费者心理学，再到正义、和平。所有这些主题都涉及情感上困难的工作。我认为我们需要关注工作者的个人生活
and experience as part of that story, not just about telling the story, but what does it mean to be a storyteller? I was doing that research, Janet Swim was working for the APA's task force on how to psychology address climate change, and I realized that she had some information that I didn't know. And so I called Janet and said, I would love to collaborate with you on this question, because I don't know how to deal with this issue of emotional stress. That's an interesting perspective, because I felt like I was there doing research on emotional issues about climate change, and I was looking for a place to do that research. So I thought I had contact you.
和经历作为故事的一部分，不仅仅是关于讲述故事，而是成为一个讲故事的人意味着什么？我当时正在做那项研究，珍妮特·斯威姆正在为美国心理学会关于心理学如何应对气候变化的特别工作组工作，我意识到她有一些我不知道的信息。所以我打电话给珍妮特说，我很想在这个问题上与你合作，因为我不知道如何处理这种情感压力的问题。这是一个有趣的视角，因为我觉得我当时正在研究关于气候变化的情绪问题，并且我正在寻找一个地方来做这项研究。所以我以为我联系了你。
and you to figure out if this would seem like a great place to do that research. But the research that I was interested in, one of the emotions I was interested in is hope. And so hope is basically transforming fear into a positive experience in a sense that you have a sense that you know what you can do. You need basic fear to start with in a sense of why you want to be concerned about this and what you want to, you know, facing the future. but when you can start thinking about your ability to do something, having a plan of action, not necessarily a big plan of action, but have a plan for how you can talk to people, then you can not feel so threatened. You can feel like you have some agency.
并让你弄清楚这是否看起来是一个做这项研究的好地方。但我感兴趣的研究，我感兴趣的情绪之一是希望。所以希望基本上是将恐惧转化为一种积极的体验，即你有一种你知道你能做什么的感觉。你需要基本的恐惧作为开始，即为什么你想关心这个问题，以及你想，你知道，面对未来。但当你开始思考你做某事的能力时，有一个行动计划，不一定是一个大的行动计划，但有一个关于你如何与人交谈的计划，那么你就不会感到那么受威胁。你可以觉得你有某种能动性。
And so working with these people in the zoos in aquarium seem like an opportunity to take this feelings of threat and help them see a plan of action and be able to then start having conversations with other people. Can you talk a little bit about what that work is within the zoos and the aquariums? We're working with the National Network for Ocean and Climate Change Interpretation. That's a National Science Foundation-funded project organized by the New England Aquarium, but it's really a vision about creating a community of practice in the zoo and aquarium community. It's bringing in people who are doing this interpretation from around the country, working with an organization called Frameworks Institute,
所以与动物园和水族馆的这些人一起工作似乎是一个机会，可以利用这种威胁感，帮助他们看到一个行动计划，并能够开始与其他人进行对话。你能谈谈在动物园和水族馆里的那些工作吗？我们正在与国家海洋和气候变化解释网络合作。这是一个由国家科学基金会资助的项目，由新英格兰水族馆组织，但它实际上是一个关于在动物园和水族馆社区建立实践社区的愿景。它汇集了来自全国各地从事这种解释工作的人，与一个名为“框架研究所”的组织合作，
who are helping structure conversation that is depoliticized and about an interaction between two people on a topic they both are concerned about. And that project, what's exciting about it is it's an unusual training program. We suggested when the project was first getting off the ground that instead of bringing one person to training, that we bring them with someone they work with every day, that they come in twos, that they work together on the problem solving, and that they've got somebody who's got their back in their own office, and those people work together in small groups of ten,
他们正在帮助构建一种去政治化的对话，关于两个人都关心的话题之间的互动。而那个项目，令人兴奋的是它是一个不寻常的培训项目。当项目刚起步时，我们建议与其带一个人去培训，不如带他们与每天一起工作的人一起，他们成双成对地进来，他们一起解决问题，并且他们在自己的办公室里有支持他们的人，这些人以十人为一组一起工作，
10 organizations. Those people work together in groups of 20, two people from each organization on developing strategies that are unique to their local community. So this project that is zoos, aquariums, nature centers, people who are doing science interpretation around the country, are starting to develop techniques and tools, but they're doing it with friends. They're doing it with coworkers. And that's part of why the psychological aspects of this are so interesting, because what we're starting to see in some of the work that Janet's leading with looking at hope is that it is about those social interactions and feeling that someone can experience what you're experiencing. So part of this is bringing your friends along, but also what you start doing when you go back to
10个组织。这些人以20人为一组，每个组织两人，共同制定针对当地社区的独特策略。所以这个项目，即动物园、水族馆、自然中心，全国各地从事科学解释的人，开始开发技术和工具，但他们是和朋友一起做的。他们是和同事一起做的。这就是为什么这方面的心理学方面如此有趣的部分原因，因为我们在珍妮特领导的一些关于希望的研究中开始看到的是，它关乎那些社会互动，并感觉到有人能体验你正在经历的事情。所以这部分是带上你的朋友，但也包括当你回到
your organization again. And so it's about the social networks that people have within the organizations, the social networks that they have with their friends and family outside of the organization. And then even when they go in and they give a program at a zoo and aquarium or other informal science learning centers, that the people they talk to hopefully will start talking to other people as well. So it's a large networks, but starting at a small scale with the people who actually are on the front line education. When you think about ideas like a disease,
你的组织时你开始做的事情。所以它关乎人们在组织内的社会网络，他们与组织外的朋友和家人的社会网络。甚至当他们进去并在动物园和水族馆或其他非正式科学学习中心提供项目时，他们交谈的人希望也会开始与其他交谈。所以这是一个巨大的网络，但从前线教育的实际人员开始，以小规模开始。当你想到像疾病这样的想法时，
a good idea can migrate around, but it requires multiple contacts. People tend to be resistant to a single contact, but multiple exposure to an idea creates a greater opportunity for it to migrate, to move in society. So when we think about people working in local zoos, aquariums, nature centers around the country, they talk to people every day. Their best friends are their go-to folks for different topics.
一个好的想法可以四处迁移，但它需要多次接触。人们往往对单一接触有抵触情绪，但多次接触一个想法会创造更大的机会让它迁移，在社会中移动。所以当我们想到在全国各地的当地动物园、水族馆、自然中心工作的人时，他们每天都在与人交谈。他们最好的朋友是他们处理不同话题的首选人物。
So when you work in a zooer aquarium, you're the go-to on nature questions. So our stories about climate change are going to come through social networks, through people we trust. And those one-time visitors may take away a bit of an idea, but the people you talk to in your social life every day, every week, when you call mom and dad. Those are the conversations that really have a chance to pick up around the country and move at a bigger level. Well, thank you so much for joining us. Dr. Swim, Dr. Fraser. This has been very, very interesting. Thank you. Thank you. For more information on Dr. Swims and
所以当你在动物园或水族馆工作时，你是自然问题的首选。所以我们关于气候变化的故事将通过社会网络，通过我们信任的人传播。那些一次性访客可能会带走一点想法，但你在日常生活中每天、每周交谈的人，当你给父母打电话时。那些才是真正有机会在全国范围内引起共鸣并在更大层面上移动的对话。嗯，非常感谢你们加入我们。斯威姆博士，弗雷泽博士。这非常、非常有趣。谢谢。谢谢。有关斯威姆博士和
Dr. Fraser's work, and to read the report of the American Psychological Association Task Force on Psychology and Global Climb and Change, visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. Association speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
弗雷泽博士工作的更多信息，以及阅读美国心理学会气候变化心理学特别工作组的报告，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。协会《心理学谈话》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。